[Musik]
ja und herzlich willkommen so salis will
was heißt das jetzt dass da fiel mir
hallo auf ungarisch jetzt kann schon mal
backen bauen und turnerische aber ich
konnte ja wegen ich lernen was aber es
hat folgenden grund heute mache ich eine
ist der hass die schnitte ich hoffe ich
habs jetzt richtig ausgesprochen
ich will ja auch nicht irgendwann später
korrigiert mich und die sagen mir wie
man das richtig ausspricht sollten wir
doch tragen ja das ist eine richtig
tolle und leckere schnitte und zwar ist
die torte glutenfrei man kann sie als
100 orte machen oder wie ich einfach als
schnitte
ich finde so als schnitte einfach
richtig hübsch vor allem kann man solche
dünnen schönen stück sich sonja sie
genau und zwar kommt der name daher
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
haben konditoren in budapest also in der
ungarischen hauptstadt diese torte
erfunden
zu ehren von paul anton esterhazy dem
dritten und das war der außenminister
des österreichisch-ungarischen
kaiserreichs und für eden wurde eben
diese torte entwickelt ok kugel für dich
gibts noch keine torte murat ja das ist
eine tolle also irgendwie eine tolle die
nach mir benannt wurden ja aber ich will
den zuschauern was und dann sagen sie
das ist murat für murat özcan den ärzten
wir noch nie den zweiten ein gefängnis
bei papa hieß ja auch vorgenommen also
einmal zur torte wir haben hier vier
böden und zwar sind das glutenfreie
bilden das heißt die torte basiert auf
bisher böden mit haselnüssen und in der
creme ist auch kein mehl enthalten und
keine weizenstärke das heißt für alle
die kein gluten zu sich nehmen möchten
ist das die perfekte torte
sie schmeckt wirklich super leicht und
sie ist vergleichbar mit der
schwedischen ahlmann die torte ja das
wird richtig lecker
ich sage jetzt zuerst einmal die zutaten
für den bc und dann starten wir auch
direkt am rhein
hallo lebkuchen ach gott bist du ein
süßes leben
jetzt will er auch okay
lecker seid ihr für das wir sehr brauche
ich sechs eiweiß eine prise salz 50
gramm zucker 125 gramm puderzucker etwas
manuell extrakt einen viertel teelöffel
zimt und hier habe ich noch 150 gramm
hasel das hat er mich bereits gerüstet
und auch fein gemahlen
zuerst nämlich das eiweiß und da müsst
ihr darauf achten dass absolut kein
eigelb drinnen stecken in einer bis auf
drin und dann wird der schnee einfach
nicht fest jetzt habe ich hier eine
saubere schüssel und auch das
schneebesen muss natürlich sauer sein
hier kommt jetzt noch das salz mit dazu
und das eiweiß wird zuerst mal steif
geschlagen
sobald der schnee fest dass der zucker
ganz langsam mit dazu und dann lasse ich
die masse für etwa zwei bis drei minuten
weiter rühren bis sich der zucker ein
bisschen aufgelöst hat jetzt ist der
schnee fällt jetzt kommt noch der
puderzucker mit rein
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
vanille extrakt reinach sieht es nicht
schön aber wirklich vanille fettkraut
schlitten dann die haselnüsse und die
habe ich zuerst gemahlen und dann habe
ich sie in einer pfanne ohne fett
gerüstet so wird einfach der geschmack
noch ein bisschen intensiver und es
duftet einfach wunderbar
jetzt nehme ich einen schneebesen und
kann das ganze vorsichtig unterheben
bisschen kleckern ist auch erlaubt
[Musik]
und ich mache jetzt eine erste harte
schnitte das heißt keine torte bei einer
torte würde ich jetzt einfach vier bis
fünf einzelne böden machen
ich mache die schnitte jetzt einfach
hier auf einem backblech mit dem eckigen
back rahmen und deswegen kommt jetzt die
gesamte masse einfach hier mit rein und
wird und später durchgeschnitten am
einfachsten lässt sich die masse dann
mit einer tankkarte verstreichen
da nämlich immer gerne die aus edelstahl
die ist nämlich richtig schön groß und
so kommt die masse jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen ich mag es jetzt
bei 170 grad und ihr könnt sie aber auch
gerne bei 200 grad ober unterhitze
backen und die braucht und so etwa zehn
bis zwölf minuten
die zwischenzeit notiert um die
buttercreme vorzubereiten ich zeige euch
mal die zutaten für die buttercreme
braucht drei kürzlich kampfstärke ich
nehme eine maisstärke vanille extrakt
250 milliliter milch und 200 gramm
weiche butter
ich gebe es zuerst einmal die eier in
einen topf und es ist auch hier ganz gut
da hat man wirklich nur noch drei übrig
für das rezept und da können sie dann
einfach ein anderes weihnachtsgebäck zum
beispiel machen oder ein leckeres lemon
curt daraus zaubern
also da gibt es ganz gut gepresst gelb
resteverwertung videos auf meinem kanal8
um eine goethe dessen wort für allgemein
gelb resteverwertung des videos darum
können wir uns drauf ich habe ich jetzt
noch die stärke mit dabei und ein
bisschen mädels jetzt kann ich das erste
mal glatt rühren
[Musik]
die buttercreme könnte jetzt mehr
verändern zum beispiel mit etwas vanille
extrakt so werde ich das jetzt machen
ihr könnt dabei auch tonkabohne mit rein
geben oder auch einfach ein schuss rum
oder auch in schnaps wie ihr gerne
möchte oder kirschwasser passt auch sehr
gut
ich nehme es manila extrakt das will
jetzt verrührt und jetzt kann ich die
creme beim mittel hoher hitze einfach
während im rühren eindecken lassen
[Musik]
die bhs ist gebacken und ihr müsst
sofort aus der form herauslösen
denn die wird jetzt auch ganz schnell
fest und dann werde ich sie raus stützen
und gleich zurecht schneiden
[Musik]
da kommt ihr sein sauberes geschirrtuch
drüber und dann nehme ich einen zweiten
toten retter und kann die platte stürzen
und die folie dann abziehen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die platte einmal
ausmessen und dann einfach in vier
breite streifen schneiden
[Musik]
und jetzt sehe ich sie auf ein abkühlen
gitter und kann sie so abkühlen lassen
und in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
buttercreme zu bereiten
jetzt ist die masse gut eingedeckt dann
musst du auch wirklich aufpassen denn
dann gibt es wirklich sehr sehr schnell
und jetzt kann ich sie direkt durch ein
sieb streichen so kann ich zum beispiel
reste von den eiern einfach entfernen
die vielleicht klümpchen gebildet haben
und danach denke ich dann den pudding
mit frischhaltefolie ab damit sich keine
haut darüber bildet und kann ihn einfach
auf zimmertemperatur abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
der pudding ist abgekühlt und den habe
ich jetzt einmal mit dem schneebesen
kurz geschmeidig gerührt und die butter
ist auch schon ein bisschen cremig
gerührt so etwa fünf minuten
und jetzt kann ich immer ein bisschen
was vom pudding einfach mit zur butter
geben und somit die buttercreme
herstellung
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die buttercreme und
streicht sie hier schon mal auf den
ersten boden
wenn ihr so eine tankkarte nimmt dann
können wir zum beispiel auch komplett
bis zum rand streichen nun richtig
sauber arbeiten
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich den zweiten boden
legen drauf und kann jetzt so die
komplette torte befüllen
[Musik]
auf die letzte schicht kommt jetzt keine
buttercreme da kommt nämlich später die
glasur drüber den rand dass ich jetzt
erstmal noch frei die übrige buttercreme
kann ich bei raumtemperatur lagern und
so stelle ich jetzt die schnitte einmal
in den kühlschrank für etwa eine stunde
bis sie fest wird und dann kann ich
gleich noch den rand bestreichen und
fertig dekoriert
so sieht die torte jetzt aus ich kann
sie jetzt gleich mit der buttercreme am
rand bestreichen aber vorher werde ich
jetzt noch den bus zu bereiten da mache
ich jetzt einen eiweiß kurs und zeigt
euch mal die zutaten für den guss
brauche ich ein halbes eiweiß 100 gramm
puderzucker den saft einer halben
zitrone einen esslöffel kakaopulver
einen teelöffel wasser und ein paar
gehobelte man sich zuerst einmal nehme
ich jetzt das eiweiß und ein halbes
eiweiß könnt ihr so auf messen indem sie
ihr trennt eiweiß und eigelb und dann
gibt mir das in der schüssel verrühren
ein bisschen wie es vorher ab und dann
nehmt einfach die hälfte weg ansonsten
ist immer ziemlich schwierigen eiweiß zu
trennen
das gebe ich jetzt hier in der schüssel
und damit eben nicht ganz froh auf die
torte kommt wird es vorher erwärmt ich
habe jetzt hier im wasserbad also ein
ganz heißes wasser habe ich eben
aufkochen lassen
da kommt jetzt der foto zucker dazu und
auch der zitronensaft obst die kallwitz
drohne gibt natürlich auch aus
zitronensaft reichten bereits aus
[Musik]
und dann wird das ganze ist verrückt und
ein bisschen erwärmt und zwar so etwa
vier bis fünf minuten sowie das eiweiß
einfach pasteurisiert und hat eben keine
keime mit drin
das wartet ab hierfür auch gerne kochen
und damit einfach richtig schön heißt
die zwischenzeit habe ich genutzt und
den rand der torte ein bisschen glatt zu
schneiden und die torte dann mit ein
wenig buttercreme einzudecken habe ich
den bus um gefüllt so kann ich ihn
einfach ein bisschen besser halten jetzt
gar nicht die oberseite der torte damit
bestreichen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier ein bisschen guss
noch übrig da kommt jetzt das
kakaopulver und das wasser mit rein und
will jetzt auch verrührt
jetzt streiche ich die oberseite der
torte noch schön glatt und zwar traurig
jetzt die palette eben das heiße wasser
und kann jetzt über den guss drüber
streichen und den restlichen gust also
den braunen gust fülle ich jetzt in
einen spritzbeutel oder nehmt eine
gerätehütte und jetzt schneide ich ja
ein ganz dünne spitze hier vorne weg und
dann kann ich jetzt so längsstreifen
über die torte ziehen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich einen zahnstocher oder
schaschlikspieß und sie jetzt einmal
eine linie so runter und einmal in die
andere richtung
[Musik]
und die spitze mache ich immer wieder in
der handfläche sauber
und jetzt kommen noch die gehobelte
mandeln außenrum das geht am einfachsten
wenn ihr detailkarten oder einen anderen
flachen gegenstand verlege ich dir jetzt
drauf und drückte dann von unten nach
oben an die torte
[Musik]
so sieht es jetzt also aus unsere
fertige torte und murat paul anton ist
schon esterhazy der dritte das probieren
wollen sie den namen sagen sie die torte
schon gefressen gästen soll so okay
jetzt pro normal also richtig cool aus
und ich bin obwohl die gesagte spießig
liga wie sie ich bin mal gespannt also
in der creme ist er kein zucker denn man
hat ja eben bc einfach schon genug
zucker und jetzt bin ich gespannt
versteckt klassischer torte und das sind
nur attrappen ja lasst den
weihnachtsmann wird auch mal probieren
der lebkuchen so ganz toll schmeckt
leicht gut geschmeckt leichter schmeckt
gut geschmeckt so richtig also so wie
vom konditor also ich find genial echt
nur das freut mich aber dass die
stückchen größer auch rot gelb aber ich
glaube mehr kann man auch von einer
torte gar nicht so viel essen wie ich
finde dann auch den anschnitt richtig
schön was du eine gelbe creme ist jetzt
ist eine buttercreme mit einem und
pudding buttercreme und ich finds halt
richtig hübsch und vor allem sieht es
sein muss sagt buttercreme ja ja
wirklich nicht und aber durch die bbc
schichten so ist die totale kontrast
alkohol das freut mich sehr wohl im
abgang
aber jetzt haben wir auch jetzt deswegen
sowohl mit klassischen erster sensorik
ja schmückt sich die leckeren und jetzt
muss aber sagen die creme ist cremig der
teig ist so echt klasse und der kran
kommt durch die mandel
ja das ganze leben ist muss erst
erschien ist das ganz toll
das freut mich falls ihr das rezept ja
auch gerne nachmachen möchte dann schaut
ob sie noch dabei
da steht es noch mal ganz genau und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und die buttercreme die könnte jetzt elf
wieder verfeinert mit vanille extrakt
das hat sich das ann kathrin poopzkid
der dampfstrahler backofen also normal
[Gelächter]